I've got a great little lesson for all of
you today in historical revisionism and gaslighting
put together.
You might be familiar with Kelly McCann.
And if he's Donald Trump's latest press secretary,
she has done a few press briefings lying regularly
for Donald Trump.
She says that Trump is the best president
ever.
She justifies anything he does and says she's
the epitome of a true brown nosing sycophant.
But she was not always like this.
As far as Trump is concerned, because back
during the 2016 Republican primary, she said
Trump is hateful and says racist things.
We have the video.
Let's take a look at it.
How sick of polls are people in New Hampshire
right now?
Probably very sick, especially when they see
that Donald Trump is number two and doesn't
deserve to be there.
The GOP didn't need to be turning away voters
and isolating them.
We to be bringing them into the tent.
Donald Trump is the last person who's going
to do that.
Haley, this is your guy.
He's number two in the polls.
Hey, I don't want to claim this guy.
The fact that the Republican Party is now
having to clean hand.
It's both unfortunate and to me and authentic.
What's the expiration date?
Been on a racist statement to me?
A racist statements.
A racist statement.
I don't like what Donald Trump said.
I don't like what Al Sharpton says.
And at what point does it expire and becomes
something that McCain Trump is racist.
Trump is hateful.
She doesn't like it.
She doesn't like him.
Now, here's the real payoff.
Cayley was asked about these past statements
by reporter.
You meet Alcindor during a recent press briefing
and her answer is the epitome of an Orwellian
look the other way, sort of answer, she says.
You know, I mistakenly thought Trump was racist
because I was reading CNN headlines at the
time.
This is her explanation.
Take a look at it.
Question I have is in 2015, shortly after
the president's and some Mexican immigrants
are rapists and criminals, you said that that
language is racist and hateful.
Do you still believe that today?
I'm actually glad you asked that because for
about the first four weeks of the election,
I was watching CNN and I was naively believing
some of the headlines that I saw on CNN.
And I know if you also person not, I'm actually
not going to read the headlines.
So I very quickly came around supporting the
president.
In fact, CNN hired me.
I was a many eight on one panels where I proudly
supported this president, who I believe is
one of the best presidents, if not the best
president this country will ever have.
But I would encourage the individual who did
that analysis of my past rather than focusing
on me.
He really should be focused on some of the
very gas CNN chose to have on their network.
He should be focused on.
I mean, my overhere, Jim Scott, Jim Clapper,
who said, you know, 10 days before you privately
told investigators there is no evidence of
collusion.
OK, so her notes for this question include
attacks on CNN guests and we can stop it right
there.
Her argument is when I said what I said about
Donald Trump, when I said he was a hateful,
racist and all that stuff, I was wrong because
I fell for CNN headlines.
I no longer fall for CNN headlines like I
did back then.
How easy to trick her, though, right?
Can she really be trusted if she so easily
fell for supposedly fake headlines from CNN?
And do we trust her judgment?
If she took a job, which with CNN, as she
says, despite believing that they are fake
news now, I really need you to understand
something.
Trump is see that and they think it makes
sense.
Trump ists are thrilled with Kaylie McEnany.
They're gleefully cheering how she's been
owning the media with these huge alpha takedowns
of the biased fake news press corps.
It is literal nonsense which only calls into
question her own judgment.
If she fell for supposedly fake headlines
and the Trump's love it, they regularly tweet
about how Kaili McInerney is just crushing
these reporters during press briefings.
Now, on principle, this explanation is absurd.
But of course, it's not just about headlines.
She came up with these opinions on her own.
It's not that she was repeating like I know
you all know that it's a dumb explanation,
but she was coming up with stuff on her own
that was anti-Trump.
I'll give you an example.
On August 6th of 2015, she tweeted, Everyone
seems to have a plan except Trump live during
a Republican primary debate.
She didn't get that from CNN.
That's her opinion.
She came up with that.
She volunteered it.
So do I think for a second that Kaylie McInerney
truly believes Trump is the best president
in history?
I don't believe for a second.
Do I think she's willing to say anything at
any time in order to justify her own career
and try to advance her own interests, which
right now includes impressing Donald?
Thrombin, having this national platform of
press briefings, of course.
And every time she tweets, every time she
speaks to the press.
That's exactly what she's doing.
And then maybe most importantly, is it working?
And the answer is on Trump.
It is trumpets are hugely impressed with her
every time she does one of these joke press
briefings.
Don Junior retweets it and talks about it.
A whole bunch of people, even people that
are only sort of tangentially involved in
politics that I know where I'm friends with
on Facebook and a sort of centrist.
Right.
Have been posting clips of Kaley McEnany and
how great and amazing everything she's doing
is it's concerning.
It's extremely concerning because she seems
to be convincing the exact people that needed
to feel like here's someone who can actually
hold their own.
Given that Trump can't during these press
briefings and Kaylie McEnany is doing it for
them again, the world is laughing.
We on the left think it's absolutely crazy
what she's doing, but the people she's trying
to impress seem impressed.
Very much so.